bonjour à tous un discours fleuve une
cérémonie en grande pompe et un concert
à Moscou les Russes voient grand pour
annoncer l'annexion de quatre régions
ukrainiennes Luans ce que donniez
scarson et zapporja le rattachement sera
officialisé demain par Poutine lui-même
Bruno ça pourrait être un tournant dans
le conflit oui ça pourrait être un
tournant dans le conflit en fait tout
dépendra de ce que veut en faire
Vladimir Poutine précisément mais disons
que il a déjà un peu annoncé la couleur
si on peut dire et il va certainement le
réitérer leur d'un discours qu'il devra
prononcer demain au Kremlin qui est déjà
annoncé comme un discours volumineux ce
qui veut dire ce sera sans doute un
discours fleuve pour justifier à la fois
les référendum l'annexion la validation
de l'annexion et justifier donc le fait
que désormais ces quatre territoires les
deux républiques séparatistes et puis
les deux territoires
occupés par l'armée russe depuis le mois
de février et bien
[Musique]
possible dans le monde donc franchement
on en est pas encore là mais il y a
cette inquiétude et puis alors l'autre
inquiétude quand même c'est que ces
annexions certes ne sont reconnues par
quasiment aucun pays mais on est quand
même un peu comme en 2014 avec une
annexion des facto à la réduction de la
Crimée est également reconnue par très
peu de pays n'empêche que depuis 8 ans
et ben la Crimée de fête appartient à la
Russie donc ça risque d'être un peu la
même chose et pour l'Ukraine c'est pas
quand même une très bonne nouvelle dans
l'immédiat puisque
et bien c'est quatre territoires
représentent pas loin du cinquième de
son territoire c'est-à-dire pas loin de
100000 km² quand même et qu'il y a en
plus de très grandes richesses dans ces
régions notamment dans le don de base
même si certaines industries comme
l'industrie minière sont en crise bon
c'est quand même pas une bonne nouvelle
pour l'Ukraine à qui il ne reste qu'une
seule stratégie c'est la reconquête
militaire sur le terrain c'est de
dégager l'armée russe de ces territoires
et on n'y est pas encore même si depuis
septembre depuis début septembre pardon
c'est clairement les troupes
ukrainiennes qui ont
l'avantage sur une armée russe un peu
essoufflée et qui visiblement a du mal à
mobiliser merci